Speaker 1: Welcome to the David Pakman show. I am
Ferron Cousins from Ring of Fire sitting in for
David Pakman today. And man, do we have a great
show coming up for you. We've got more potential
charges that could be filed against Donald Trump.
We've got Jim Jordan getting smacked down by
Manhattan District Attorney Alvin Bragg. We've got
MAGA freaks coming out in droves to attack former
Trump lawyer Jenna Ellis. All that and much, much
more is coming up. So let's jump right into it. As
I mentioned, there could be a new avenue for Jack
Smith, the special prosecutor with the DOJ, to
charge Trump with even more crimes than previously
thought. Thanks to a ruling last week, a three
judge panel actually overturned a lower court
judge, Carl Nichols, who was appointed by Trump.
Nichols had ruled that prosecutors trying the
Capitol rioters could not charge those individuals
with obstructing an official congressional
proceeding. The official proceeding, of course,
being the certification of the Electoral College
votes. And for some reason, Judge Nichols said
nope. Even though they very obviously obstructed
and postponed that hearing through their actions.
You can't charge them with that. So then late last
week, a three judge panel voted 2 to 1 that, yeah,
yeah, you can charge these individuals with
obstructing an official congressional proceeding.
Now, what's important about that, according to
former Assistant Manhattan District Attorney
Andrew Weissman, is that now that this three judge
panel has given permission for prosecutors to use
that obstruction charge, Weissman says that
Jack Smith could now, with that permission.
File those same charges potentially against Donald
Trump. Let me read you what Weissman had to say
during an appearance on MSNBC's Morning Joe. This
is really a gift for Jack Smith, because as good
as it is for the Washington, D.C., prosecutors
who have hundreds of pending cases who want
to know that this is a charge they can continue
charging, Jack Smith is going to be thinking about
this obstruction charge with respect to the former
president. There's nothing better for Jack Smith
than to know that this has already been approved
by the D.C. Circuit, meaning he can charge it.
And unless the Supreme Court disagrees with the
D.C. Circuit, he knows that this is a rock solid,
legally a legal rock solid charge, that he has
to prove it factually. But getting the sort of
pre-clearance is unusual to have, and he has to be
happy that the court ruled that this is a charge
that will stick for any potential charge. He is
thinking with respect to the former president.
A lot to take in, right? Let me distill that
down to its most basic components. Obviously,
the first thing you have is the United States
Supreme Court. It's likely this will obviously
be challenged and head to the U.S. Supreme Court,
at which point the justices most likely, given the
magnitude of this charge, I don't think they'll
take it up. I think they'll look at that three
judge panel ruling 2 to 1 vote and basically come
to the decision. We don't want to wade into this.
If they come to that decision, they will say,
nope, we are not taking the case. The D.C.
Circuit's decision stand. That clears the way for
Jack Smith, of course, to hit Trump with these
obstruction charges if they choose to take it up.
God only knows how that's going to end up. Right.
We have seen this court. Absolutely. Railroad
legal precedent. We don't know. So there's a
big question mark over that. So 5050 chance they
take it up, then? If they take it up, 5050 chance
there that they rule that, yes, you can charge
these individuals. So let's assume for a moment
that Jack Smith gets the clearance. The Supreme
Court either doesn't take it up or rules in favor
of the D.C. Circuit, and Smith can charge Donald
Trump with obstruction of an official proceeding.
That's a relatively minor charge compared to,
obviously, everything else that Jack Smith
is investigating. So if Smith moves forward and
decides to charge Donald Trump with obstruction,
it's going to be a very minor charge on top of
everything else that he could potentially be
charging him with. So it's basically a way to
just kind of pad everything a little bit more.
But I don't think that's where Jack Smith
is really wanting to put all of his chips.
Because to me, what I'm reading into this.
Is that if you can charge any of these people
involved in the events of January 6th with
obstructing an official government proceeding.
That is something that Jack Smith can then use as
a bargaining chip against any of the individuals
who may not want to cooperate fully with the
investigation. Maybe we want to plead the Fifth.
Maybe we we don't want to come talk to you. Maybe
we want to challenge these subpoenas. Of course,
we've seen all this happen so far, to no avail
on the part of most of the people that have
been subpoenaed. But this would give Jack Smith a
really great bargaining chip because it's a fairly
simple and easy charge to prove. And it's also
something that most prosecutors would not want to
waste their time pursuing. But if he can take that
and dangle that potential charge in front of any
witness that may not want to fully cooperate and
say, listen, you don't have to tell me everything,
you can plead the Fifth if you want. But I just
want you to know that here in my back pocket.
I have obstructing an official government
proceeding and I can charge you with this.
It's very obvious that your involvement on that
particular day led to the postponement of that
Electoral College vote. And that is illegal.
So I don't want to hit you with these charges,
but I am more than willing to do it if you do
not cooperate. Now, some people may hear that
and think, wow, that kind of seems a little little
underhanded. But trust me, it's not. Things like
this happen all the time in criminal prosecutions
and investigations across the country. Every day
when you can find those little smaller charges,
you know, the obstructing government proceeding,
obstruction of justice, by the way, is usually
the bargaining chip that prosecutors will use.
To get people to testify and come forward with
information basically offering an immunity deal.
Right. Like, I'm not going to charge you with this
as long as you give me all of this. It is very
common. And to me, that kind of seems like the
most likely avenue that Jack Smith would pursue
if he gets the clearance to bring those charges.
That's not to say that he's not going to go ahead
and tack that on to Donald Trump, because I do
believe that's something you could do just to,
you know, stretch out whatever else you got. Why
not hit him with everything? And that is probably
what would happen if he's able to do this again.
It's going to depend on the Supreme Court. That's
one of those wait and see moments that I know none
of us like, but that's where we stand right now.
Could be a new charge against Donald Trump, could
be a bargaining chip. Either way, the wind's at
his back, Right. Jack Smith holds all the cards
right now, so let's see what he does with it. B